everyone knows that Tara is going out
they're gonna buy three billion dollars
for the Bitcoin dokwan one of the
founders of the Terra ecosystem also has
aspirations to buy up to 10 billion
dollars of Bitcoin over time they're
going to take that Bitcoin and put it in
the reserves of their stable coin UST
but there's a recent video where do Quan
was talking about why the hell he's
doing this and what are some of the
ramifications well listen to this exact
part I found this fascinating in terms
of his analysis I think if we scale that
to you know 10 billion dollars so the
reason why I want to get to 10 billion
is that besides to Sushi we will be the
largest single holder of Bitcoin in the
world now then in that case like within
the crypto industry then the failure of
UST is equivalent to the failure of
crypto itself now that's absolutely
crazy to think that somebody who went
ahead and launched a stable coin could
actually use those reserves and acquire
so much Bitcoin that they became the
second largest holder of Bitcoin in the
World Behind The Creator Satoshi
Nakamoto there's a lot of people who
don't like what they're doing there's a
lot of people who think it's pretty
interesting regardless of where you fall
on this you have to be paying attention
whenever you have a persistent buyer
somebody who's willing to buy up
billions of dollars of Bitcoin and their
price insensitive they're buying 125
million dollars a day or so you better
pay attention because they create a
change in the market dynamics and
ultimately they're one of the main
drivers of why the Bitcoin price has
been rising over the last couple of
weeks dokwan wants to become the second
largest holder of Bitcoin in the world
let's see if he can accomplish it hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time